this episode is sponsored by wandrium
stick around until the end of the
episode to find out more
in the popular imagination of many
people across the world Islam is sadly
associated with war and violence with
you know reporting on the instability in
the Middle East as well as things like
terrorist attacks by extremist Muslims
coupled with a lack of education and
understanding on the Islamic world and
its religion this is perhaps
unfortunately somewhat understandable
this is why it's so important to
encourage and provide that kind of
education which can counteract black and
white perspectives on the world indeed
the role of war in Islam is a lot more
complex and multifaceted than many
people realize and Concepts like Jihad
are often greatly misunderstood or at
the very least oversimplified
questions of the legitimacy of violence
and War in Islam have always occupied
Scholars from the religion's Inception
until today and there have been many
different perspectives and rulings in
different times and places when it comes
to such subjects as well as the question
of Muslim non-muslim relationships these
perspectives fall along a spectrum with
what we could call intolerance and maybe
harshness on one side and tolerance and
maybe even pacifism on the other
while we're not going to cover this
broad topic as a whole today instead
leaving that to a future episode we're
going to look at a particular example of
an Islamic tradition that strongly
emphasizes a non-violence and peaceful
coexistence a kind of pacifist form of
Islam that flourished in West Africa and
which is specifically associated with a
scholar and an Islamic jurist called
al-hajj Salim sawari and the so-called
sowarian tradition
[Music]
[Applause]
Islam has an incredibly strong presence
in West Africa the overwhelming majority
of people in countries like Senegal The
Gambia and Mali are Muslim and the
religion has a long and complicated
history here but this wasn't always the
case and previously in history West
African Muslims found themselves living
alongside and sometimes under the
leadership of non-muslim pagan
inhabitants of the region
this resulted in debates among Muslim
Scholars regarding how one should
approach such a situation how does one
conduct trade and business with
non-muslims are Muslims allowed to live
under non-muslim even Pagan leadership
how does one conduct missionary work to
spread the religion and should Jihad in
the form of armed War be used as a tool
for this it wasn't until the 19th
century that countries like Senegal
became majority Muslim and this was in
large part thanks to strong opposition
to French colonialism at the time and
even at that point and maybe even still
today these kinds of discussions have
erupted in this region and in the
Islamic World in general in a previous
episode we explore the life and
teachings of Amadou Bamba a Sufi Saint
and founder of the muridia Sufi order
who emphasized non-violence and
education as the only legitimate
response to Colonial oppression rather
than war or violence
he is certainly one of the most
significant figures in West African
history and his non-violent policies
have been very successful
but these kinds of ideas were not
unheard of in the region before many
earlier figures sufis and Scholars had
taken a similar position and Bamba
certainly had much earlier scholarship
to rely on to a certain degree and when
talking about the non-violent or even
pacifist Islamic tradition in West
Africa there are few figures as
significant aside from Bamba as al-hajj
Salim sawari he was a powerful and
highly revered Muslim cleric and jurist
from what is today Mali in West Africa
he belonged to the soninka people and
started a kind of movement based on his
teachings which became known as the
sowardian tradition so what his name is
often preceded by the title al-hajj
which is a common title in the region in
particular to denote someone who has
done the long and difficult pilgrimage
to Mecca the so-called Hajj in fact
sawadi was famous for doing the
pilgrimage seven times which is an
incredible feat at this time so if you
were doing the Hajj from Iraq for
example it's still impressive right at
this time in the Middle Ages but
comparably not as long of a distance to
go and you don't have to walk as far if
you're gonna walk from all the way from
West Africa in Mali to Mecca now that is
pretty impressive and seven times two
right so you know
he had the respect of the people for
maybe a good reason the main problem
with sawadi is that we don't know much
about his life there is in particular a
huge debate in scholarship about dating
some Scholars such as lamin or sunny
believe that he lived around the 12th to
13th century While others such as evil
Wilkes instead plays his death around
the year 1500 which is obviously a
significant difference a couple of
hundred years there are good Arguments
for both sides and I'm not going to be
making an argument here even though I do
tend to lean towards the earlier date
instead I'm going to leave it to you to
decide for yourselves what you think
regardless the dating of his life does
not change the the basic facts about his
teachings and the Legacy that he has in
this region living in West Africa sawadi
established a community based on his
understanding of Islam and Islamic law
that tackled some of the most pressing
questions for Muslims living in this
region at the time the vast majority of
people were after all no non-muslims
following the indigenous religious
traditions of West Africa and on many
occasions Muslims thus found themselves
living under non-muslim Kings this Taps
into some of the most significant
discussions in Islamic law regarding
questions of missionary work the status
of non-muslims and Jihad and sawari
would largely adopt what we can call a
pacifist stance the word pacifist should
be somewhat nuanced here though because
the Quran seems to allow at the very
least war on violence in terms of
self-defense there are few examples of
an absolute pacifism in Islamic history
Jihad is a word that is complicated in
itself it does not mean holy war as many
assume but rather a struggle or striving
and this can mean various different
kinds of striving and struggle it came
into struggle against your ego the Jihad
and nafs that the sufis often talk about
it can mean to struggle to be a good
person struggle in charity and struggle
for the betterment of the environment
for example but it can also of course
mean struggle in the form of armed
conflict or war and on some level this
form of arm Jihad has usually been
considered a legitimate and often
important aspect of Islam in particular
in self-defense or in protecting the
borders of Islamic lands Jihad has been
a sort of communal obligation of sorts
but the details of these ideas are
complex and Scholars have debated them
across history there is a long tradition
within Islam of just war war needs to
have a proper defensible justification
and during war certain rules need to be
followed pretty Universal across these
Traditions have been rules such as the
prohibition of killing women and
children or non-combatants in general
prohibition against burning crops or
killing animals as well as always giving
the enemy the opportunity to resolve
things peacefully before engaging right
so always offering the options to either
convert to Islam or to pay a tax that
allow them to freely practice their own
religion these rules basically come from
the hadiths and reports of the prophet's
life it is said that the prophet when
their Community would go out into a
battle would hold a speech and would lay
down these basic rules as would later
caliphs like Omar for example in any
case these kinds of questions became
very important as Muslims spread into
new lands such as West Africa for
example
some scholarly communities saw it as an
obligation to spread the rule of the
Islamic religion by War if necessary and
there was impermissible for Muslims to
live in lands ruled by non-muslims often
referred to in the Middle Ages as the
DAR al-harab the Abode of War as opposed
to the dadal Islam the Abode of Islam or
sometimes the Abode of peace right the
the Salam but others disagreed instead
holding more nuanced and complex views
of this situation al-hajj Salim suwadi
was one such figure so what it was as we
have said an eminent Islamic scholar and
jurist in particular like most Muslims
in Western and Northern Africa he
belonged to the Maliki School of Islamic
law founded by the early Muslim figure
Malik IBN anas in Medina suwadi had
studied deeply the main texts and
sources of the Maliki school and was an
expert on Islamic law particularly as
understood through a Maliki lens and his
whole mission in life was dedicated to
educating the people in West Africa on
proper Islamic practice and how to live
alongside non-muslims
and While others may have chosen a more
hard-line position favoring things like
offensive Jihad as a necessary means of
spreading the religion so what it took a
rather quote-unquote liberal or tolerant
approach
The Scholar evil Wilkes wrote quote
conflicts between the proponents and
opponents of jihad as a means of
economic social and religious change can
be traced back in the West African
context to early Malika jurists who were
Gravely concerned with the spiritual
consequences for those Muslim traders
who were increasingly conducting
business especially in Golden Heights
with non-muslim opposite numbers in the
deserts and grasslands to the South
sawadi and the large clerical community
that he started which became known as
the yakanke became known particularly
for their strong disavow and rejection
of arm Jihad as a means for religious or
political change all the sources and
current Traditions attest to this fact
sawadi seems to have seen Jihad as a
counterproductive and harmful way to
spread or indeed represent the religion
of Islam instead sawadi seems to have
emphasized education and peaceful
interactions as the Better Way Forward
he said to have gone on several peaceful
missionary Journeys into Senegal and The
Gambia among other places where he would
speak to both Muslims and non-muslims
about the importance of education and
his rejection of om Jihad in this
context his perspective seems to have
been one where the best way to spread
Islam and to gain convert so to say
which was the ultimate goal after all
was not to take over by force but to
provide a positive example by being good
people and neighbors and peacefully
educating about the religion this would
be a much more successful way of doing
missionary work now as I said before
this pacifism needs to be nuanced suwade
would have agreed with the Quran that
violence or war was legitimate or
justified in circumstances of
self-defense as well as probably in
other context as well but in terms of
political and religious change
of sort of of achieving political or or
religious change in this context he saw
it as completely
counterproductive and illegitimate it
was not a viable option to him based on
his understanding of the Quran and
Islamic law particularly as understood
through the Maliki school as we said in
fact he wanted no involvement in
politics or a secular rule at all and
this is a stance that would characterize
his movements across history after his
life also in talking about this topic
The Scholar Ivor Wilkes lists seven
points which represents sawani's
position on Muslim on Muslim relations
as explained by scholars in the current
Jeweler community that has maintained
and represented his teachings over the
centuries
he says quote
first kufer unbelief is the result of
jahel that is of ignorance rather than
wickedness
second God's grand design for the world
is such that some people remain in the
jahiliyah the state of ignorance longer
than others
third true conversion can therefore
occur only in God's time and actively to
proselytize is to interfere with his
will
accordingly fourth Jihad against
unbelievers is an unacceptable method of
conversion and recourse to Arms is
permissible only in self-defense should
the very existence of the Muslim
Community be threatened by unbelievers
fifth Muslims May accept the authority
of non-muslim rulers and indeed
supported insofar as this enables them
to follow their own way of life in
accordance with the Sunnah of the
Prophet sixth the Muslims have to
present the unbelievers with khudwa
example and so when the time for
conversion comes thereby make possible
emulation
and seventh the Muslims must ensure that
by their commitment to education and
learning they keep their observance of
the law free from error
end quote again this isn't necessarily
based on any writings by Subaru himself
and I'm personally skeptical of some of
the points here for example the third
point that proselytizing should be
avoided seems to clash with other
sources that point to the actual
missionary activities of suwadi himself
on top of honestly just not making much
sense for a Muslim to say
it seems likely to me that suwadi and
his communities certainly is sought to
spread Islam but rejected an enforcible
way to do so indeed the Quran does state
that there is quote no compulsion in
religion and the general rule in Islamic
law has been that forced conversions are
not allowed even though they did of
course happen occasionally
Scholars like sawadi seem to have taken
it even further by rejecting Jihad as a
means of spreading their religion
altogether
instead as we saw in the quote
emphasizing showing good example and
emphasizing education and peaceful
proselytizing in his missionary travels
he not only preached but also
established mosques in a kind of kind of
a whole educational system actually one
that became very significant for the
future of Islam and education in the
region Wilkes again says quote whatever
his dog trailer positions however
al-hajj Salem's main claims to
Innovation lie in the pedagogical field
over a large part of West Africa the
institutional framework within which
teaching has been organized seems
largely his work
Salim sawari became a very influential
figure being referred to in his time as
the Sheikh al-shoyor the Sheikh of
al-sheks he had hundreds if not
thousands of followers during his
lifetime and stories even tell of how he
founded the city of the acha bamboku or
the akaba which became a significant
City and Center for Islamic clerics in
particular he had founded a major
community of clerical Elites dedicated
to education non-violence political
non-involvement and proper Islamic
conduct
this community became known as the
yakanke and which would spread across
all of West Africa and Beyond thus
making Suarez teachings available in
many different places even today there
are significant communities and many
people Scholars and leaders who are
influenced by or have inherited the
sowardian tradition
indeed this is possibly visible in the
very dramatic events of the 19th and
20th Century as countries like Senegal
and The Gambia in many ways took on the
form that they have now
interestingly the sowardian tradition
and way of thinking seems to have
eventually become influential on the
sufis of the qadri order in particular
that will become very prominent in this
region the 19th century was a very
turbulent time for a Senegal in
particular it saw a lot of conflicts
between tribal leaders several violent
examples of jihad and connected to this
the gradual colonization of the country
by France in response to this situation
there were many Muslim leaders and
Scholars that emphasized and supported
RM Jihad as a response to this situation
While others rejected it in favor of
other tactics the famous figure of alhez
umartal for example led a large Jihad in
the region against what he saw as
unbelievers both non-muslims and Muslims
who failed to uphold correct practice
and created a kind of state the tokelor
Empire which lasted for only a few
decades but as a response to his
campaigns many other Muslim Scholars
were critical
figures from or influenced by the
yakanka community associated with sawadi
repudiated umartal and advised against
his Jihad similarly the famous qadri
Sufi leader Ahmed al-baqahi also
strongly condemned and criticized tal
for his extremism and unlawful use of
war and violence as the French colonial
power started to establish themselves in
the region there was a similar response
many chose to fight back with arms
whereas others favored peaceful and
non-violent cooperational responses very
interestingly and this is a big
generalization we can observe that the
figures who chose the path of jihad arm
Jihad were usually associated with the
tijaniya Sufi order including
by contrast Sufi leaders and Muslim
Scholars from the qadri Sufi order were
more likely to reject violent responses
and favor peaceful means sometimes even
cooperation with the French we saw
earlier that sawari and the sawarian
tradition seems to have been influential
on the qadri order in particular and we
might speculate that there is some kind
of connection here could we go as far as
to say that the great figure of ahmadu
Bamba is one representative of this I
don't want to say that his non-violent
stance was a direct result of sawarian
teachings we should view Bamba as his
own person with his own ideas of course
but Bamba was after all before founding
his own muridi order a member of the
cladity order of Sufism
could it be that Bamba was somehow
indirectly or directly influenced by a
scholarly environment that was infused
with sowardian tendencies in Bamba's own
non-violent Jihad against French
colonialism he emphasized education as
the best way to create social change and
rejected RM Jihad and violence as
counterproductive and destructive to the
Muslims and the well-being of the region
in general he also used similar
arguments as those attributed to suwadi
that it is completely permissible to
live under non-muslim leadership in this
case the French as long as the Muslims
living in that land were still allowed
to practice their religion it's hard to
say for sure but what we can say is that
both
and ahmadu Bamba represent a similar
pacifistic tendency within Islam an
emphasis on non-violence and education
as a more proper way to spread the
religion and live alongside other people
peacefully this is not unique to West
Africa and these discussions haven't had
across Islamic history and day what
we've explored in this episode is only
one particular example of how this
debate has been had in a West African
environment in particular and how the
influential Maliki scholar Salem sawari
created a tradition of non-violence and
peaceful coexistence that became infused
in many different communities in the
region influencing events and attitudes
even into the Contemporary World Senegal
and The Gambia is indeed a unique case
where the relationship between religion
and secular state has an interesting
setup in the modern world that seems to
work out pretty well and where different
groups of people can live together
without any major problems perhaps this
contemporary situation can be traced not
only to Modern figures like Amanda Bamba
but also further back in history to
foundational Scholars like sawadi West
Africa is indeed a very significant
region for the larger Islamic world but
one that isn't talked about as much as
it maybe should be and that is why it's
so great to have services like today's
sponsor bondrium
one dream is an online learning platform
with an ever expanding library of
educational content led by experts and
made by incredibly talented people it's
really high quality stuff they have
everything from courses again led by
professors and and Scholars experts in
their fields you have long form and
short form documentaries about various
topics you can learn a new language you
can learn how to play the piano you can
learn about various religions which
would be of course relevant to what
we're talking about here the library of
content is always expanding and they're
adding new stuff and it's really high
quality material I've worked with one
gym in the past and we keep this
collaboration going because they are
really the perfect fit for this channel
learning and and studying new things is
obviously one of my passions in life as
well as to educate people and share that
passion of learning with you that is
what this whole channel is about and I
feel like what one dream is doing is
also very is similar to that they have a
similar role of providing trustworthy
and reliable educational content that is
just also really engaging and
entertaining to watch like I said they
have stuff about basically any subject
that you can think of in terms of what
we've been talking about today there are
courses on religion you can learn about
Islam and the history of Islam for
example there are courses dedicated to
that in particular I think for this
episode we've been talking about West
Africa there is a new series that
they've just released on one dream
called discovering West Africa this is a
really entertaining travel documentary
style series led by Nathan flewellen
who's a kind of travel influencer it is
a great way and a fun way to learn about
the people and culture of West Africa
from an appreciative and really
entertaining point of view in the series
Nathan explores three West African
countries in particular Cameroon Ghana
and Senegal and explores everything from
boxing to music even Sufism and other
topics just a lot of really interesting
stuff so I highly recommend you check
that out if you want to learn more about
West Africa which is the topic we've
been talking about today and if you are
interested in learning more or in one
dream in general you're in luck because
one dream is offering a free trial to
the let's talk religion audience head
over to onedrim.com let's talk religion
or click the link in the description to
start your free trial today thank you so
much to wondering for sponsoring this
video and I will see you next time
[Music]
thank you